did you fall in love with fleabag well
start getting used to life without her
endlessly witty remarks they're good
right chic chic means boring don't tell
a friend series mastermind Phoebe Waller
bridge created wrote and starred in the
hit show portraying a young woman who
uses sex humor and an imaginary audience
to cope with difficult emotions while
Waller bridge just revealed that the
emmy-winning show won't be getting a
third season at least not anytime soon
please note in case you aren't
completely caught up with flea bag
there's going to be some spoilers ahead
during an appearance on Late Night with
Seth Meyers Waller bridge revealed that
she has no immediate plans to revisit
flea bag a character she originally
conceived on the fly for a stand-up
sketch I quite like the idea of of
coming back to her and me when I'm 50
right because I feel like she would have
had you know more life then and God
knows what what she would have gone up
to she goes on to say actually seeing a
character like that in her later stage
of life is exciting but for now she's
been through enough we've got to let her
go
in fact Waller bridge never even planned
for fleabag to get a second season in
August 20 19 June Fallon on The Tonight
Show that I was very smug about not
coming back because I thought I had a
lot of artistic integrity and not coming
back after the first one because the
first season had a proper ending in my
mind based on Waller Bridges 2013
one-woman show flea bag eventually did
receive a fantastic second season which
centered around fleabag falling in love
with Andrew Scott's hot priest since the
second season wasn't originally in the
cards it's easy to believe while a
bridge will eventually change your mind
about making a third season while that's
certainly a possibility it sounds like
it probably won't happen for a few
decades but really it might be best if
it doesn't happen at all it's rare to
find a series as well-written funny and
moving as fleabag so it's only natural
to want new episodes to come out every
year that said it's also rare that a
series maintains such a high level of
quality throughout multiple seasons both
seasons of fleabag were nothing short of
marvelous the show was pitch perfect and
expertly executed from the first scene
to the last a scene that finds flee
and the priest confessing their love for
one another let's just leave that out
just the second anytime then they say a
tearful goodbye and split up with smiles
on their faces
this unexpectedly touching ending caps
off the unique love story of fleabag and
the priest setting the priest back on
the right path and putting fleabag on a
path where she can start to heal and
eventually shake off her
self-destructive tendencies this
conclusion also leaves the story wide
open and on a surprisingly hopeful note
fleabag and the priest can hold the
memory of each other in their hearts and
the two of them can realize their
personal goals independently in the
first season fleabag finds numerous ways
to avoid dealing with her grief and
trauma and she finally begins to
confront these issues in the second
season that made the series finale
poignant in all the right places and it
never got overly soapy fleabag realizes
that she needs to stand on her own two
legs without constantly checking in with
the audience that only she can see as
vultures catherine van Aran donk put it
she ends the story she's been telling us
while also turning toward her own life
her own family her own relationships
with people who can speak back to her
it's why the ending is such a perfect
conclusion to the series and why it also
feels so crushing in the end we bagged
breaks up with us breaking up is never
easy to do but sometimes it's necessary
and when it comes to fleabag it's
definitely for the best check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]